yeah I I've always had that spring yeah
it is freezing cuz my allergies are
kicking like karate I just figured that
out
my wife my my eyes it you got a houses
sniffle yes bring home I don't suffer I
got a house is sniffles it was really
bad runs in Denver I have to take
[ __ ] whatever they call it claret and
every day yeah in LA I don't wow it is
literally today right yeah okay that my
body went hey [ __ ] it's spring yeah
it's your eyes don't wonder I'm so bring
forward no wonder I'm so damn horny
spring it up
I want to spring it up I love spring see
you like [ __ ] mating I want a mate
hard and true that's the system you in
the [ __ ] eyes let's do it like the
donkey's do oh let's do it like the doc
yeah my [ __ ] you better hard up you
dog I'm allergic to some pollination and
dick and dick I'm going to get dick
thank god you're not allergic to dig I'm
allergic good it's my spring dick don't
you want a hug so you're gonna dig it
out why cuz my eyes are a burning I
swear to God and this is not appropriate
set of podcasts cuz she listens to it
tonight your wife solutions I'm gonna
look at her and I'm gonna go time for
some spring dick no I'm gonna go like
this
I'm gonna spring your baby and this cuz
I have children but I'm gonna say this
let me come out as far as I can go we're
gonna spring you live absolutely not
this is my [ __ ] wife I know I can
it's the spring annual [ __ ] fest I come
out of the closet just covered in
dandelions and my dick rock pile I go
yeah time to spring on you [ __ ] no
absolutely the dig on day three of your
spring rapist no working on this
together
no I as her husband I'm gonna go today's
your lucky day and she's gonna go wide
I'm gonna go it's the first day of
spring and you bout to work this spring
sapling this spring stalk the spring
what's in bloom sweetie
that's not gonna do and I'm gonna have a
daisy the stems shoved right into my my
pee hole
boy here we go talking about dick and
your wife
I was just talking about a spring
gangbang you could be mad that I got all
wheeze give me madami
don't be mad meet a man yeah I was
you're talking about coming out of my
closet yeah with my covers and
dandelions and go spring forward bit
well and then I'll call cops know my
business partner Brennan job is covered
in dandelions come here he's very big
man wrong card right now offering to
tasers and I need five guys cuz he's way
stronger than you and he's horny which
means he's gonna be handy and he's
looking to [ __ ] come in and all he keeps
shouting is spring for days that [ __ ]
Taylor [ __ ] and I want his I want to
handcuffs on his wrists and we're gonna
wrap his dick up in a big old piece of
rope bring a coarse hemp rope it's gonna
it's not gonna feel comfortable and
yanked that thing up nobody tougher in
Hollywood it's just nobody tougher in
Hollywood besides maybe the rock and
well yeah and that in the rock but
there's the rock this right there's the
rock and then there's Frank Grillo yes
and Frank buyer Lopez yep Mario Lopez
I'll give him Mario Lopez give you rough
room I understand he's he knows his way
around a boxing ring he was wrestler so
do me a favor when you see Mario Lopez
and I you know I love you yeah and
you're a tough guy when you see my on
your favorite here friend you shake his
hand you thank him for his work you tell
them that you tell me for five minutes
train I got up and you're calm AC Slater
comments later you do no idea you go hey
it's okay I gotta go fire right away its
brand doc shop do you know Rendon no
Brenda Brenda yeah somebody tweeted me
yesterday brownish up with a really
weird quote and I go oh man yeah I don't
think that's really what the quote was
yeah I see a lot of random [ __ ] I'm
gonna look it up now because there was
Sheriff I hope I yeah Brenda come on so
sometimes like when you insert certain
things I won't do that many letters so I
leave off the end no Brenda shop see oh
no [ __ ] no this isn't me
this is Brendan Schaub at Shaw berry
Finn but look at zeros boss hooch if you
are thinking about something bad don't
do it something good Double Down
I definitely didn't do that but the
rates spelled also right yeah it's
simpler see that's me yeah definitely
not me though no but also the way she
says something something less um thi n
might have missed a couple English
classes in high school that's hooch in
River Fabiano yeah yeah yeah there we go
he came to me when they shared that says
I'm the boss I think Oh sir hey boss you
were spelled your name wrong and I go
who I was born with it no no no no
pretty sure I got this she dumped ass
ass best that's no that's boss what is
she so open I'll never forget the one by
my testosterone doctor call me up on
there he goes what a [ __ ] you been
because we became friends and I go doc
let me tell you what happened I didn't
wanna coy I was embarrassed I had a lot
of red blood cells I was getting
headaches and he goes hmm he goes in 40
years of shooting testosterone this has
only happened the two people and both of
your human why I just where to God yeah
but then you have yo land [ __ ] the halls
like I'll try it yeah he eats the bottle
he just got that [ __ ] bottle yo but he
looks great there tested him now he
looks great
that's dog listen those Cubans genetics
man listen oshi national wrestling team
like he's a free dog but those Cubans
member they have that Cuban that African
blood the Africans went there as slaves
like if you look at my sister she's
[ __ ] dark really yeah we all it's
like I got a cat I got two cats
Phinney Demi and Harry they're brothers
if you look at them he's a Siamese you
look at Harry he's a Siamese but he's
not a leopard colors to him because
every like six generations that leopard
comes out it's the same in my family if
you look at my uncle he's blacker than
black if you look at my cousins to ban
in Cuba my cousin the female is
dark-skinned but her brother is me weird
so that African
keeps coming up he's got him freaks well
he's got that if you look at different
african-americans you could tell what
tribe they came from like Dave Winfield
and John Jones his tribe it was tight
like I'm saying if we Dave Dave Winfield
with six foot six built I saw him at
breakfast one that's on an airport yeah
that dude did meet to lift weight no you
know then you have the other tribe Earl
Campbell and [ __ ] like a Jim Brown
tribe Jim Brown tribe like they were
like in Nigeria somewhere you can
actually break down the strength
yomo marrow euro marrow and arrow
Campbell are cousins they came from like
the same tribe the thick legs you know
axes they all like you could see and
that's what happened in Cuba those good
athletes and I think that that like I'm
scared to send in the ancestry.com thing
like I've been thinking about sending it
in but I know they're gonna come back
with like [ __ ] my cousin was Kunta
Kinte but I know it going in do say like
yeah this is this Cuban family and
Pasadena and I go up there for the
holidays and I'll bring like afro-cuban
music and when I put it on they lose
their mind because they know they're
black they just don't want to be realize
good dance they don't know they don't
want to be reminded me I know it's in
there somewhere
so I put it on
[Laughter]